[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Today, I'm very
pleased to introduce
two professors, Avner
Ash and Rob Gross
from Boston College,
the math department.
We'll be speaking about
"Summing It Up From 1 plus 1
To Modern Number Theory."
I think is a great title.
And to me, speaks to what I find
fascinating about real math.
The way that seemingly
simple properties
of integers, addition,
and so on yields
this wonderful rich complexity.
And so, here to introduce
that, Avner and Rob.
AVNER ASH: Thank you, Richard.
[APPLAUSE]
It's a real pleasure to be here.
And thank you for
organizing this.
I'm going to speak
for about 10 minutes
and try to explain
what is number theory.
And then, Rob is going to give
a worked out example of number
theory.
And then, I'm going
to talk for 10 more
minutes about other stuff.
So what is number theory?
And probably maybe a lot
of you know this already.
But it's studying the
properties of whole numbers,
1, 2, 3, 4, and so on.
And it has a long history.
One of the nice things about
working in number theory
is you feel you're connected
to a long intellectual history
going back to at least the
ancient Greeks and probably
other ancient peoples.
In Plato's dialogues, there are
a lot of-- very simple number
theory is often used as
an example of something
you can know for sure.
And the example
Socrates always gives
is the fact that some numbers
are even and some are odd.
Well, that's pretty simple.
But that's the first
basic fact about numbers.
They divide up into
these two parts.
And then, people started
playing around with numbers.
You also get in the
ancient world, people who
are interested in numerology.
You know, like seven
is a sacred number.
And 6 is equal to 1 plus 2
plus 3, which are its divisors.
And the Pythagoreans
especially were
interested in number theory
from that point of view.
But as a real theoretical
subject in mathematics,
the only really important number
theorist in the ancient world
was Diophantus.
Who lived quite a few
centuries after Plato.
And he invented the
study of what we now
call Diophantine Equations.
And I'll give you an example of
one of those in a few minutes.
Another interesting thing about
the history of number theory
is that it went to sleep
after Diophantus pretty much.
And for centuries--
this has something
to do with what I'll be
talking about in my second part
of my remarks.
It went to sleep
and people didn't
seem to be very
interested in it anymore.
And the person
who woke it up was
Fermat, who was a lawyer
in France in the 1600s.
And he just got
interested in numbers.
And a big difference
between what he was doing
and what the ancients
could do is that algebra
had been invented by that time.
So Fermat could use
algebra to study numbers.
And he got all kinds
of interesting ideas.
There were a lot of other
people at the time interested,
like Descartes.
And then, the subject picked up
and has been an important part
of mathematics ever since.
When you get to
the 20th century,
there are all kinds of
famous number theorists.
One of them was
Hardy, the guy who
discovered ramanujen-- whom you
may have seen a movie about.
Hardy was famous for saying
that number theory had
no applications at all.
And he was really glad
of that, because it
meant his hands would never
get dirty with warfare
or anything nasty like that.
A kind of very pure vision
of what number theory was.
But the big change-- I was
talking about this at lunch.
The big change in number theory
in the last 40 years or so
is that suddenly you got
these applications, right?
The cryptography and cyber
things, cyber security.
All right.
Well, that was the
history of number theory.
So it has to with whole numbers.
And I'm going to
give you the example
of Fermat's Last Theorem of
something in number theory.
But I wanted to just
fill it in a little bit
with some personal
history of my own.
In 1993, there
was this one night
when I couldn't sleep at all.
It was the only time I haven't
been able to sleep because
of some mathematical reason.
I mean the whole night.
It was the night
after the day when
I heard that Andrew Wiles had
proof Fermat's Last Theorem.
And some of the details of
the proof had also been given.
And so, I just thought
about it all night
how these details figured out.
It was just the most
amazing thing that
has happened in number theory.
Probably the most amazing
thing in mathematics
in the 20th century.
You may know the story that it
turned out his proof was not
quite correct.
And it had a gap in
it, which was later
filled in with the help of
his student, Richard Taylor.
And so, two years later it
became a definite theorem.
But since that time, I've been
fascinated with his proof.
And I immediately wanted to
be able to explain that proof
to non-mathematicians.
It's a very complicated,
very subtle proof
with many, many different parts.
But that's the origin
really of our first book.
So Rob and I have written
three books about this.
And this was the first one.
So there are basically
three ingredients.
Three abstruse ingredients that
go into Fermat's Last Theorem.
One of them is Galois
representation,
whatever they are.
And we devoted
this book to trying
to explain to--
literally, I wanted
to explain to my sixth grade
daughter and other children
what a Galois representation is.
As it turned out, that
was shooting a little--
that was a little optimistic.
But I think we did
explain it to someone
who really didn't know much
math, but could handle algebra.
Anyway, that was the
Galois representations.
The second big ingredient in the
proof of Fermat's Last Theorem
we covered in this book, that's
the theory of elliptic curves.
Which are certain
cubic equations.
And then, in our
most recent book,
The one we came to talk
about is the third ingredient
that Andrew needed.
Which was modular forms.
So I'll tell you
a little bit more
about the contents
of those books.
But quickly, here's his
Fermat's Last Theorem.
And this is an example of a
statement in number theory.
Because it's about ordinary
positive whole numbers.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, and so on.
You may know you can have
a 3, 4, 5, right triangle.
That means 3 squared plus
4 squared equals 5 squared.
So two squares can
add up to a square.
Fermat's Last Theorem says that
higher powers can't do that.
Two cubes cannot
add up to a cube.
Two fourth powers cannot
add up to a fourth power,
and so on, and so forth.
That turned out to be
very hard to prove.
It's famous, because Fermat
claimed he could prove it.
But no one believes that
he really had a proof.
He made some kind of mistake or
he was writing a little joke.
I don't know what it was.
So what we've tried
to do in our books--
so for each of those
three topics I mentioned,
each of those
topics can be rooted
in something very elementary.
So for example, modular forms is
rooted in just infinite series.
Just infinite sums.
And infinite sums,
that theory is
rooted in finite sums,
which is just addition.
So what we did in summing
it up, we divided the book.
All of our books are divided
into three parts, like Gaul.
The first part is meant
to be very elementary.
Really your sixth grader,
if she's motivated enough,
should be able--
she has no algebra.
But with just a
high school algebra,
you should be able to
read that first part.
And there, we talked
about finite sums.
And in a couple
minutes, Rob is going
to give an example of what we
talk about in the first part
of the book.
Then, in the second
part of the book,
we assume that
you know calculus.
And so, if you know calculus,
one of the topics in calculus
is infinite series and limits.
And so, then we can go
and discuss that topic.
And then, the third part of the
book is about modular forms.
And that's quite difficult.
But if you're motivated enough,
we hope that you can read
that part of the book as well.
We wanted to know,
who are our readers
after we published these books.
And so, we get email.
No sixth graders have
written to me yet.
I did make my daughter
read the book,
so I know at least
one sixth grader.
Well, she only read
the first part.
So our readers though, turn
out to be-- a few of them
are like high school students,
math whizzes from high school.
We got some college students
and graduate students.
And I would say the majority
of people who send us email
are STEM professionals.
You know, engineers,
physicists, chemists.
Often retired, who have
time to read the book.
But I think the range
of emails shows me
that we're reaching
the kind of audience
that we wanted to get to.
So anyway, I think I'll let
Rob discuss now just one topic,
so you can see in great detail
what a typical number theory
question is and how
you might answer it.
ROBERT GROSS: OK.
So this is going to get hard,
but let's start with something
easy.
Let's add up 1 plus
2 plus 3 plus 4.
OK.
Well, why are we doing this?
So there's this old
story about Gauss.
And I'm actually going
to ask if anyone in here
wants to tell the
story about Gauss
rather than me doing this.
Does anyone know this
story about Gauss?
Yes!
Why don't you just go right
over there to the microphone,
since you're right over there?
And just go through it.
AUDIENCE: My
understanding is that he
was given some busy work along
with the rest of the class
to add up a list of
numbers, perhaps 1 to 100.
And he had the
insight right away
that you could add
them all to each other.
ROBERT GROSS: OK.
What's interesting is that
that's one way the story goes.
That's what's in Calingers book,
which is a standard textbook.
The busywork part all
the stories agree on.
If you look in Polya,
Polya says it was adding up
the numbers from 1 to 20.
Now, Polya is not a historian.
He is a mathematician.
And then, you look in
what's undeniably a work
by a historian of math,
Eric Temple Bell's
"Men Of Mathematics".
And he has this really
intricate problem involving
adding up 100 numbers.
But it's not 1 to 100, it's
something way more complicated.
The trick will still work.
But it's a little hard
to pin down the details.
And I'm not so sure
the whole thing ever
happened given this variation.
So let's recapitulate
what you just
said for the people who aren't
familiar with the story.
If we're going to add up
1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4,
we can run the numbers
in the other order.
And now, the key observation
is to add vertically, so 1 in 4
is 5.
2 and 3 is 5.
3 and 2 is 5.
4 and 1 is 5.
S and S is 2S.
And now, we have this
labor saving device
of multiplication.
Because we don't need to
add 5 to itself four times,
we can multiply.
And we get that
twice the sum is 20.
And therefore, the sum is 10.
OK.
Now, that works in
general if we're
adding up the first n numbers.
We can write them
from left to right.
Write them from right to left.
Add vertically.
Use multiplication.
And divide by 2.
That works for a lot of sums.
It doesn't work for all sums.
So the next problem
that one would consider
where this method
doesn't work is adding up
squares rather than just
consecutive integers.
Square the numbers
before adding them up.
This problem seems to
date back to the Greeks,
so it is a natural next step.
I need a little notation here.
Let's call this S2,
because those are squares.
And let's call the
original sum S1.
This same idea
doesn't work if you
write them from left to right,
write them from right to left
and add.
It doesn't work.
OK.
So that's not going to fly.
And I want to show you
two different methods.
The first method is
very complicated,
but I want to show it to
you just because it's a way
to make this left to
right, right to left method
work with a little
bit more effort.
But this is quite
complex and you'll
need to look at it
afterwards more carefully
to see what's going on.
OK.
It's a sort of two
dimensional version.
You could say to
yourself, the first method
isn't going to work again.
Because left, right,
right, left isn't enough.
We're dealing with squares,
we need two dimensions.
So 1 squared is 1.
2 squared is 2 plus 2.
3 squared is 3 plus 3 plus 3.
And 4 squared is 4
plus 4 plus 4 plus 4.
So let's take our sum and make
those substitutions going down.
OK?
And now the idea is
that we've actually
turned a one dimensional left
right approach into a triangle.
There are actually
two different things
you can do that will work.
You might be able to make
something work about diagonals
if you try hard enough.
But I'm going to
go across instead.
And so, the first sum is S1.
The next one is
not quite our sum.
It's S1 minus 1, because
we're missing the 1.
The next line we're
missing the 1 plus 2.
And finally, the last line
we're missing 1 plus 2 plus 3.
OK?
So now, if we add down
the right hand side,
we have our desired result
S2 is four times S1.
That's the first column
on the right hand side.
Minus a whole lot
of other stuff.
OK.
So now, here's where
it gets complicated.
We're going to rearrange
that whole lot of other stuff
using our formula for S1.
OK?
Those little terms in
parentheses in there
are all sums of
consecutive integers.
So we're just going
to rearrange them.
So here's our formula.
And instead of 1--
well, that's really
the sum of the first integer.
That's 1 times 2 over 2, when
1 plus 2 is 2 times 3 over 2.
And 1 plus 2 plus 3
is 3 times 4 over 2.
We'll factor out the 1/2.
We'll do a little
bit of rewriting.
We have some squares showing
up when we do the rewriting.
1 times 2 is 1 squared plus 1.
And 2 times 3 is
2 squared plus 2.
And eventually, we
end up with S1 minus 4
and S2 minus 4 squared
in the parentheses,
which is really neat.
And that's going
to work in general.
OK?
If S1 is the sum of
the first n integers,
then S2 is the sum of
the first n squares.
That same method ends up giving
this very complicated formula
here, S2 is n times S1 minus
a bunch of other stuff.
We know what S1 is.
We can do some algebra and
we get our desired answer.
So that method can
be made to work,
but it wasn't really good.
It's quite complicated.
Let me give you a
little homework.
So the sum of the first
n cubes, we can call S3.
Use the same trick,
expand out the cubes.
Do the same idea and you can
eventually with a lot of work
show that the sum
of the first n cubes
is n squared times n
plus 1 squared over 4.
It's not easy.
I'll give you a
little more homework,
which is much more interesting.
The sum of the first n integers
is n times n plus 1 over 2.
So show directly that if you
add up the first n integers
and square it, you get the
sum of the first n cubes.
I'm actually going to
give you a little bit more
of an assignment.
Not only do that algebraically,
but you should also
do that geometrically.
What's on the left
hand side is a square.
Take that square,
make it height 1.
Turn it into a solid.
Chop it up and reassemble
it into the cubes
on the right hand side.
So you can do that.
And it's very enlightening.
But here's a more
motivated proof.
OK?
Not going to look
that way at first,
but eventually it will work out.
Let's take this polynomial
out of thin air.
x cubed over 2 minus x cubed
over 3 minus 6 squared over 2
plus x over 6.
This has the wonderful property
that if you plug-in x plus 1,
plug-in x into a polynomial and
subtract, you get x squared.
OK?
There's some algebra
there, but your telephone
can do the algebra for you.
So you can trust me on that.
And so, plug-in
first x equals 1.
And you get f3 of 2 minus
a f3 of 1 is 1 squared.
Plug-in x equals 2,
you get the next line.
Plug-in x equals 3,
Keep going all
the way down to n.
And we get this line over here.
Now, the right hand side is
exactly our desired result.
The left hand side looks like
it has 2n terms, but all but two
of them cancel.
Notice that the f3 of
2 on the first line
cancels with the f3 of
2 on the second line.
The f3 of 3 on the second
line cancels with the f3 of 3
on the third line.
There are only two terms
left when you add up
the left hand side there.
f3 of n plus 1 and f3 of 1.
The right hand side
is our S2, which
is the thing we care about.
And we just expand f3 of
n plus 1 minus f3 of 1
and get the desired answer.
So this magic polynomial f3
solved the problem for us.
So obvious question is,
where did this come from?
OK.
So this is just about
a Bernoulli polynomial.
Not quite.
I'm going to tell you what
a Bernoulli polynomial is.
Several different ways in fact.
OK.
The Bernoulli polynomials
are polynomials of degree k.
There's one in each degree.
There's a B1.
There's a B0.
There's a B2.
B2 is quadratic.
B3 free is cubic.
B4 is quartic.
OK?
The first one, B0, is
just the constant 1.
And then, there
after we define them
by saying each
Bernoulli polynomial
is just about the integral
of the one before it.
Not quite.
Multiply by a constant first.
I'll explain why in a second.
And integrate.
Now, if you define
something by integration,
there's this constant
of integration
that's undetermined.
And we're used to picking
constants of integrations
being 0, but we're not
going to do that here.
We're going to pick the
constant of integration,
so that this polynomial has
the same value at 1 as it
does at 0.
I'll show you some of these
polynomials in a second.
But those three lines completely
determine the Bernoulli
polynomials.
You start out at 1.
Integrate after
multiplying by a constant--
I'll explain why in a second.
And pick the constant
of integration,
so that the polynomial
has the same value of 0
as it does at 1.
OK?
The reason that we're going
to multiply by a constant
before integrating is to
make each polynomial begin
with x to the k.
If we don't multiply
it by a constant,
we start building up
denominators in the first term.
So here are some
of the polynomials.
We start with 1.
We multiply and integrate.
And we get x, the minus 1/2 is
this constant of integration
that's picked out.
So that the next
polynomial will have
the same values at 0 and at 1.
We integrate x minus 1/2.
And then, make the
first term start
as x squared rather
than x squared over 2.
And the next constant of
integration is going to be 1/6.
Here's one more.
Again, integrate the previous
line after multiplying by 3
so that you end up with x cubed
rather than x cubed over 3.
There is no constant of
integration here as it happens.
And here's one more.
OK?
So they're not
that hard to find.
And they all satisfy--
this is the key.
If you plug-in x plus 1
and plug-in x and subtract,
you get not x to the k minus 1,
but k times x to the k minus 1.
And that's good enough.
So these are actually the
polynomials we're looking for.
They're not easy to
find, but they're
the ones that have this
property that if you
plug-in x plus 1 plug-in x and
subtract, you get a monomial.
And the key point
is the monomial then
can be added up to give
us the powers of integers.
OK.
So here's an example.
If you plug-in x
plus 1 and plug-in
x into the third polynomial.
And again, better to let
someone who is error-free,
like your computer do
the algebra than for you
to do the algebra.
You end up with 3x squared.
And then, if you
divide by 3, you
end up with the polynomial
we started with.
Because we want to
get an x squared
and that's the magic that lets
us add up the first n integers.
OK.
And the formula then is B3 of
x1 minus B3 of 1 divided by 3.
OK.
Here's formulas for the sums
of the first n k-th powers.
For k going from 1 to 7, we
saw n times n plus 1 over 2,
n times n plus 1
2n plus 1 over 6.
I want to put this
on the screen,
because it's a great
example of something that
almost never happens in math.
Every single
conjecture you can make
about this formula based on
these tables is actually true.
OK.
So there's nothing
misleading here.
Very often there
are patterns that
are true for the
first 10 integers
and then they just go haywire.
Here, they're not going haywire.
The degree goes up by one
each time, you can see that.
Each term is divisible
by n times n plus 1.
That's always going to be true.
In alternating degrees,
there's a 2n plus 1.
That's always true.
After k equals 1, the
odd k's all have n
squared times n plus 1 squared.
There's more stuff that
you can't tell from here.
But if for example,
you graph them,
they're all symmetric
about minus 1/2.
Which is kind of neat.
And there are even more things
if you multiply them out.
For example, the coefficient
of the next to highest term
is always 1/2.
Very mysterious.
Very nice.
So that's actually neat
and you can play with that.
You can find this
table in lots of places
if you want to play with them.
And it is fun to make
conjectures and prove them
in that way.
The constant terms are
the Bernoulli numbers.
OK?
So those constants
of integration,
which were picked to
make the polynomials,
have the same value at 1
and at 0 are these numbers
called Bernoulli numbers.
After the first three-- 0, 1,
and 2-- the ones with odd index
are all 0.
So I can omit them.
And they're very
mysterious fractions.
The only pattern that
you can directly see
is that they alternate in sign.
And that is not
that hard to prove.
Other patterns are
pretty hard to prove.
And I feel obligated to
show you some gobbledygook.
Because the usual way of
defining Bernoulli polynomials
and Bernoulli numbers
is to write down
this formula for the
Bernoulli polynomials
in terms of these things
called binomial coefficients--
which I'm not going to explain.
And then, to say that
the Bernoulli numbers
satisfy this very mysterious
formula at the bottom.
Which again, I'm not
going to explain.
And then, that is the way
people typically define them.
Yes?
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Why did you
only have [INAUDIBLE]?
ROBERT GROSS: Because these
ones that I omitted were all 0.
OK?
Yes.
All of the odd ones are 0.
And a very hard exercise
is that people often
start by writing
down this formula
on the bottom of this screen.
And then saying, OK.
Start with that definition
of the Bernoulli numbers.
And now, I'm going to prove
that all of the odd ones are 0.
It's extremely hard to do that.
It can be done.
If you look in some 100-year-old
books, you'll see that way.
There is I have to say, a
much more motivated approach
to this in our book then
even the one I'm giving now.
But this was one
quick way to get
to these very
mysterious numbers.
They show up in number
theory all the time.
They were involved in one
of the methods of trying
to prove Fermat's
Last Theorem using
something called Kummer theory.
Wasn't quite successful,
but they feature critically.
They also show up in calculus
in a place where you've never
seen them.
When you study
calculus, if you get
to the end of the
second semester
and you're still
paying attention--
the teacher tells you there's an
infinite series for sine of x.
And she tells you there's an
infinite series for cosine x.
They're pretty nice formulas.
The teacher never
tells you that there's
an infinite series for tangent
of x, because it's not quite
such a nice formula.
And in fact, it has the
Bernoulli numbers in it.
A result of that along with some
knowledge about infinite series
is that you can show that
the coefficient in front
is actually a positive
integer-- which
is a extremely mysterious fact.
The Bernoulli numbers
are fractions.
But multiply them by this very
complicated 4n, 4n minus 1
divided by 2n.
And you end up with it.
And then, make
the sine positive.
You end up with a
positive integer.
A very strange fact.
Bernoulli numbers show up
in one more interesting way
that I can tell you now.
I'm going to make a detour here.
I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So it's
not at all obvious
why there's a connection between
these particular polynomials
and tangent?
ROBERT GROSS: Correct.
AUDIENCE: Is there a
succinct reason for that?
ROBERT GROSS: Yes.
OK.
So the question is
it's not obvious
why these numbers have any
relationship to tangent.
Is there a succinct reason?
The answer is yes.
The numbers actually can
be related to e the x.
And that's actually the
approach we take in the book.
e to the x-- if you
substitute i theta for x,
can be related to
sines and cosines.
And then, there actually are
some complicated trigonometric
identities to get
tangent into the picture.
Which is where those 4
to the n's come from.
So that wasn't
succinct, but I hope
it gave you a little bit
of idea what's going on.
AUDIENCE: Question back to-- OK.
So why e to the x?
ROBERT GROSS: That is
actually a good question.
That actually turns
out to be the best
way to define the
Bernoulli numbers.
And so, that's the approach
we take in the book.
They come from the infinite
expansion of the function
x over e to the x minus 1.
That's actually the easiest
way to work with them.
Start there and deduce
all of the properties.
AVNER ASH: So you're still
not answering his question.
ROBERT GROSS: OK.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
OK.
AVNER ASH: That if you do
what he just said about e
to the x over x
or whatever it is,
you'll get the Taylor
coefficients there will satisfy
certain recursion
relations that turn out
to be identical to the
recursion relations we wanted
at the beginning to solve
our problem about sums of k
to the powers.
Solve maybe you could
call it a coincidence.
But that's why it happens.
ROBERT GROSS: Yeah.
OK.
It is extremely
beautiful and extremely
mysterious is what I would say.
And it's nowhere
near as mysterious
as the next connection, which
I will tell you about now.
So back about the
time that Bernoulli
was doing that other work, there
was a famous unsolved problem
which appears to have the
name the Basel problem.
It's to add up the
numbers 1 plus 1/4
plus 1/5 plus 1/16 forever.
An infinite sum.
This is the second
part of our book.
The question is, what is it?
OK.
Well, it's 1.649.
OK?
Dot, dot, dot.
That's not a
satisfactory answer.
It is pi squared over 6.
Let me give you a little
bit of background here.
I'm not going to show you that.
This is rather hard to prove.
It again, involves
in one approach
trigonometric identities.
Which is where the Bernoulli
numbers are going to come in.
It can be derived using
Fourier series, which again
have trigonometry in them.
So that's one approach.
There's an approach involving
identities, involving
cotangent and cosecant-- which
again, involves trigonometry.
I don't think there's a
trigonometric metric-free way
to derive this formula.
So a little bit of notation.
We're going to call
zeta of k-- that's
that strange letter over there.
The sum of the reciprocal
of the k-th powers.
Zeta of 2 is our
subject of interest.
Zeta of 3 is 1 plus
1 over 2 cubed.
And so on.
And Zeta of 4 is 1 plus
1 over 2 to the 1/4.
And so on.
So Euler showed that zeta
of two is pi squared over 6.
He solved the Basel problem.
He also essentially
had an identity
that let him keep going.
Once he had zeta of 2, there's
a kind of complicated formula
that relates zeta
of 4 to zeta of 2.
And zeta of 6 to zeta 4.
And zeta of 2 and so on.
So you can actually keep going.
And he worked out that zeta of
4 is pi to the forth over 90.
Using the identity again,
he worked out that zeta of 6
is pi to the 1/6 over 945.
This wasn't part of
the Basel problem.
Euler seems to have
been having fun.
And he got all the
way to zeta of 12.
OK.
They're all even powers of
pi divided by something.
And this is an amazing story
that not many people know.
He got to zeta of 12.
He said 691 is in the numerator.
I know where else
the 691 shows up,
it's the 12th Bernoulli
number numerator.
This is absolutely true.
And a phenomenal bit of insight.
Euler said, I can
prove a formula
that relates the even
values of the zeta function
to the Bernoulli numbers.
So what's going on
here is we started
by trying to add up
squares and then cubes.
Then, we went to infinite
sums of reciprocals
of squares and cubes.
And the Bernoulli numbers
show up in both places.
There's no good reason for that.
So then, the next question to
ask is zeta of odd numbers--
and here, the answer
is more complicated.
No one knows about
zeta of 3 or zeta of 5.
Very little is known.
Certainly not that it's
pi cubed times something.
Or pi to the 1/5 over something.
You have to answer
a different question
to get increasing powers of pi.
You have to add odd
numbers, not all numbers.
And sometimes you have
to take alternating sums
rather than all plus signs.
And then you can get
a formula involving
increasing powers of pi.
So with that, I'm going
to catch my breath.
And I'll go back and let
you chat a but further.
AUDIENCE: So as a
non-mathematician,
I have to ask you, is it weird
that you ask these questions
about series of things
that have integers in them.
And the answer has a
transcendental number
on one side and an
integer on the other.
And it's a weirdly
arbitrary looking integer.
Is that as weird as it seems?
ROBERT GROSS: Yes!
AVNER ASH: Yes.
Yes.
That's exactly what
I was going to say.
Is that what Rob's little
demonstration here shows
is that if you start off
with the whole numbers
and you're just interested
in the whole numbers,
It doesn't matter.
You're forced to move on.
If you want to
understand whole numbers,
well, first you have to
understand fractions.
And then, we see transcendental
numbers starting to pop up.
We see calculus, we
need to use calculus.
And this is what Richard
said in his introduction.
You start with the simplest
objects, the whole numbers.
And if you want to understand
them as best you can,
the subject just
grows and grows.
And it moves you
upwards, so that you're
learning about more
different kinds of numbers.
And then, you get
to complex numbers.
A square root of minus 1.
That's really
important if you want
to go further in number theory.
So that's one of the beautiful
things about the subject.
Probably one of the reasons,
again, why the ancient Greeks
couldn't get very far with it.
Because their concept
of number was too much
tied down to commensurability.
But in modern
times, we have this
is amazing growth
of the subject.
It just keeps growing and
getting weirder and weirder.
And more and more
mysteries are popping up.
And every so often
we prove something.
You know, Andrew Wiles
proves something.
And that gets a little
bit [INAUDIBLE].
So now, we know Fermat's
Last Theorem is true.
But that opened up a whole
bunch of other mysteries
about Galois representations
in modular forms.
So the question I
wanted to raise now,
is why would anyone be
interested in whole numbers
or in any of this?
And I want to talk
about that a little bit.
And then, we're hoping to have
a question answer discussion.
And I'm really interested to
hear from you in the audience
if you have any
ideas about this.
But as we were writing our books
and thinking about our audience
and meeting our
friends-- and the friends
say, what are you working on?
I'm working on
this number theory.
There's a certain small
percentage, maybe 5% or 10%
of your friends who say, oh,
that's really interesting.
And you sit down and
they'll listen to an hour.
You can talk for an
hour about this stuff
and they get into it.
And the other 90% say,
oh, that's interesting.
Their eyes glaze over.
I'm sure that those of you
who are in technical fields
have had similar experiences.
So one question I have is,
why does the population
divide up like that?
For one thing, where does
curiosity about whole numbers
come from?
And that I don't know.
But for myself, I remember being
interested from my earliest
memories.
Like when I was
6-years old, I learned
about casting out nines.
And then, I would just
write down lists of numbers
and add them up.
And then cast out the nines
and see that it worked out.
That was like a great mystery.
When I was a bit older,
I learned some algebra.
I just liked solving
simultaneous equations
into unknown.
Linear equations and
plugging in the answers
and seeing that it worked out.
I don't know.
Is my brain wired that way?
My father was a physicist.
Maybe it has something
to do with his tutelage?
So I was going to
ask you, how far back
were you interested in
math and number theory?
ROBERT GROSS: A long way.
And I actually
remember working out
some of those formulas
in that table way
before there was an internet.
And I actually was
told that if you add up
the 1/5 powers of numbers from
1 to n, you get a polynomial.
And I remember working
this out by hand.
And checking the answer.
It was great.
AVNER ASH: So this
doesn't really
give us any insight into
why we were interested.
Why we became mathematicians.
And then, the other
side of the question
is, why are so many
people not interested?
And that seems to be at least
partly a cultural thing.
Because we were discussing
this also before the lecture
that in other countries,
like Russia and France,
many more of the general
public-- at least
they have some interest
in mathematics.
Mathematicians
can be rock stars.
There's a French
mathematician who
is like a rock star over there.
And there's just
much more attention
paid to mathematics in
some other countries.
But I don't think that's
really the whole answer.
Is it that there's something
in American culture
that is designed to
turn students off?
Could it be that all sixth
graders, if they were just
allowed to play around with
numbers by themselves--
or most of them
would be interested?
But there is something
in our-- that they're
getting some kind of message
that it's even nerdy to be
interested in mathematics.
Or in girls it's not girly.
You know, if you're a
girl, you shouldn't do it.
And then, you should be
doing sports instead.
I really don't know.
But it's important if
you're writing books
for the general public
about mathematics,
you want them to be
interested in it.
In the preface to
our book-- you know,
I thought a lot about when
we were writing this preface.
How do we hook a reader?
Of course, I don't
know what they're
doing in the science section
anyway of their book store
or of Amazon.
But they look it up and
they look at the preface.
And what are we going
to say to grab them?
And we never figured out
a good answer to that.
Basically it says, if
you are interested.
If you are curious about
the properties of numbers,
then this is a book for you.
And we'll go back as
early as you want.
We'll start off with the
most elementary concepts
that you might want.
Addition is about as
elementary as you can be.
And we can build up from there.
But what gets a person
interested at the beginning?
I don't really know.
And I'm very curious about that.
So there's one
other possibility.
As we saw it from
Rob's talk-- and then
you all know this anyway
from any mathematics
that you may have studied
in school, or in college,
or whenever, it starts off
slowly and then it builds.
So it's always
building on itself.
And if you can't kind of retain
several different layers,
you get lost.
Students get lost.
It's not like a
literature course,
where first read this novel.
And then, you read that novel.
If you didn't
understand "Moby Dick",
you can still understand
[INAUDIBLE] or something
like that.
But in mathematics,
there's much more
of this process of layering.
And I think that might
be why a lot of people
drop out of the
game at some point.
But I still don't
understand from early
on why more people aren't
interested in this really
wonderful subject that
we've devoted our lives to.
So that's I think
all I wanted to say.
Anything to add?
ROBERT GROSS: I want
to hear what they have.
AVNER ASH: We'd really like to
hear any questions or comments
that you might have.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Actually while we're
talking about the subject,
my daughter is
actually home schooled.
So it's kind of a
different experience.
But it's still kind
of curious, because we
use this program called IXL
or something rather like that.
And it's very interesting
in what they try to do,
because they're trying
to teach kids mathematics
but they're doing it
incredibly computationally.
My daughter got pretty good.
She's a 9th or 10th grade
in high school equivalent
right now.
And she got pretty
good at calculating.
And she was like
really impressed
that she could calculate
10 digit numbers.
And I at some point
revealed to her, well,
that's great calculation.
But it has really very little
to do with mathematics.
And then, it turns out she
got interested in chemistry
on her own more or less.
And it's interesting.
Because I can see
with the chemistry,
I can talk to her about
the things about patterns.
How [INAUDIBLE] and bases.
And notice how the
numbers on this side
have to be the
numbers on that side.
And guess what?
That's just equality.
That's the mathematical concept.
And when she sees that stuff,
it's very interesting to her.
Now, the part with getting
her to do the actual
work to solve the
hard problems, that's
a little more challenging.
But there is the
interesting stuff.
A lot of stuff I
think that gets taught
these days is computation,
because computation is easy.
You can easily measure it.
You can say, oh, did you
get the right number?
It's like, well, OK.
You got the right number.
But that doesn't
give you much clue
as to whether they
got any insight
from getting that number,
which is a much harder problem.
And I think that's
where the problem is.
It's not so much that we
have bad teachers per se.
It's that getting
people to get concepts
is actually a very challenging
thing and a very, very
hard thing to measure.
And so, you've given as
you saidd-- your students
with the lowest GPA's
the hardest problem.
How do you measure how someone
else is going to succeed?
Anyway, so just another--
AUDIENCE: I had a
technical question for you.
AVNER ASH: Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: So the zeta functions.
Because they involve greater
and greater exponents,
does that lead to
faster converging
numerical estimations for pi?
ROBERT GROSS: It would
except the power of pi
is higher each time.
And it turns out to
pretty much average out.
AUDIENCE: Really?
Because the square root
algorithms for example.
ROBERT GROSS: Right.
But the error seems to go--
if you compute zeta of 100
and relate that
to pi to the 100.
And then, take the
hundredth root,
it's not the right
way to compute pi.
There is a lot of number theory
involved in the right ways
to compute pi.
But the zeta function turns
out not to be a good way.
It's very disappointing,
because you would only
need to add one or two terms.
AVNER ASH: But there's an
interesting separate issue
there that you raise.
And I'm not an expert
on this, so I might
say something that's incorrect.
Maybe you can--
But as Rob showed you,
zeta of even numbers--
so those are the
reciprocals of squares,
fourth powers, sixth powers.
That infinite sum is known.
It's a power of pi times a
rational number, it's easy.
And then zeta of the odd
numbers are pretty much unknown.
ROBERT GROSS: Completely
AVNER ASH: Zeta of 3.
Zeta of 5.
Except there's one
thing that's known.
That zeta of 3 is irrational.
It's not a fraction.
That's the only one, right?
ROBERT GROSS: It's possible.
AVNER ASH: Any zeta
of 5 is known also.
ROBERT GROSS: Yeah.
I'm not sure.
But very little is known.
And it's not hard to
go back to your office
and get zeta of 3
computed to 100 places.
Divide by pi cubed and
hope to spot something.
We've all done it.
And it's not anything.
But maybe it's not pi cubed,
maybe it's pi to the 3/2.
AVNER ASH: Oh.
ROBERT GROSS: You could
play all afternoon and see.
AVNER ASH: What I
was going to say
though is if I
remember right, the way
this guy proved that
zeta of 3 is irrational
does have to do with the rate
of convergence of a series.
ROBERT GROSS: Yes.
AVNER ASH: So it's known that
if a series converges really,
really rapidly a certain
type, then it cannot converge
to a rational number.
That's a kind of combination
of calculus and number theory.
And now, the series
for zeta of 3
itself doesn't have that
fast convergence property.
But the [INAUDIBLE]
figure out some ways
of manipulating it and
relating it to some very fast
quickly convergent series.
Is that right?
ROBERT GROSS: No.
Entirely correct.
AVNER ASH: Yeah.
And so, that's the amazing
thing about this subject.
You never know what
other part of mathematics
is going to come in to be
useful in understanding
just these properties of
these simple whole numbers
and fractions.
AUDIENCE: Regarding
the question of how
do you interest people
in number theory.
Given that unlike
in Hardy's times,
there are actually applications
for number theory now.
Is there a story
to tell there where
people might be interested
in the applications
and the number theory is
actually possible for people
for laypeople to understand?
AVNER ASH: Yeah.
I think so.
I mean I think that books
have been written about that.
So if you look at the range
of books of mathematics
for sort of the general public,
then there are different types.
And one type is to concentrate
on these applications.
And that's one good method.
That's something we sort of
wanted to avoid in our book.
Because we wanted to try to put
this out as something as very
pure and theoretical.
Just because that's
how we view it.
But that's a good way to go.
Another way is to talk
about the biographies
of the mathematicians.
That's pretty popular.
And then, there are
quite a few books
that just treat the
mathematics itself,
but they usually start
at a higher level.
And what we wanted to do
was to bring this down
at least at the
beginning of each book.
To bring it down to the lowest
possible level we could.
The last one summing it up is
a little bit more difficult
to actually.
The algebra gets
heavy really fast.
If you look at our first book,
"Fearless Symmetry", in a way
that's harder to understand,
because it's more abstract.
But in terms of the
math that is involved,
the whole first eight
chapters involve
nothing but addition,
subtraction, multiplication,
and division.
And yet, we're studying some
very interesting properties
of numbers.
Namely if you divide one
number by a prime number,
you get a remainder.
We're interested
in those remainders
and how they fit together.
And that's the beginning
of the story that leads on
to these Galois
representations that
are important in the proof
of Fermat's Last Theorem.
AUDIENCE: I think I could
provide a little insight
about mathematics
in Russia as I'm
a college student from Russia.
So actually, mathematicians
and engineers
are not viewed as rock stars
in Russia at all-- at least
in the general public.
But if you're interested,
and motivated.
and you want to attempt
some early school
and get into the STEM
field at some point,
you have opportunities.
At least in the
big cities, there
are very good and famous
schools with great curriculum
in math and physics.
And like proofs are all
over math curriculum.
If you don't get into
the right school,
you can probably still
attend a math circle
starting from middle school.
Which again, exposes
you to number
theory, calculus starting
from fifth grade or something.
That's how I personally got
involved in the math field.
AVNER ASH: In fact,
down the street
from where I live
there's something
called the Russian
School Of Mathematics.
I think there for
schoolchildren to give them
supplementary education
in mathematics.
I was just going to say--
maybe this now will be obvious.
I was going to
summarize by saying,
why should we get people
interested in mathematics?
Besides selling our book.
You know, who cares?
So just to summarize.
But I think you've all
probably heard this before.
First of all, mathematics
is the language of nature.
That's what Galileo called it.
SPEAKER: He didn't
have group theory.
AVNER ASH: Well, actually
group theory turns out
to be just as much there.
But he didn't know.
Yeah.
Well it was very
insightful of him.
Yeah.
Mathematics is the
language of nature.
And so, people who might not
be interested in mathematics
per se-- I mean most people
are interested in some part
of the natural world.
And if you want to
be a good citizen,
you need to know your
basic mathematics.
And there's all these
horrible stories
in the newspaper
about people don't
have any financial literacy.
They don't understand
compound interest.
global warming.
Things like that.
All those kind of
things would be
better served if we--
and I think maybe we
as a society are slowly moving
in the direction of making
mathematics more accessible
and more fun for all people,
not just for this 5% or 10%
who get born interested.
And then, finally we
want to have people
going into the STEM areas.
We need more and
more people educated
in mathematical sciences,
and engineering, and so on.
And so, you need a
bigger pool to draw from.
So I think those are all good
reasons for writing books
like these and
trying to get people
interested in mathematics.
SPEAKER: Well,
thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AVNER ASH: Thank you.